des numéros d'équilibristes de la
jonglerie des acrobaties ces élèves sont
exemptés de cours toute la semaine c'est
le cirque qui vient à eux on propose aux
enfants une initiation aux arts du
cirque on est vraiment sur la découverte
on n'est pas on n'est pas là pour en
faire des artistes de cirque l'idée
c'est vraiment leur faire découvrir
notre milieu notre monde et à travers le
monde du cirque leur proposer de la
pédagogie
sous le chapiteau les exercices
s'apparente à de l'éducation physique et
sportive
et ce ne sont pas des vacances avant
l'heure en classe nous ont fait tout un
retour donc il ya un travail de
vocabulaire d'expression écrite et orale
que les plus petits on travaille aussi
du coup le cas muller du sucre en
anglais on va rencontrer des oeuvres en
arts visuels et des des artistes comme
kader chaplin nos enfants on travaille
différemment parfois on sent même pas
compte qu'ils sont en train de
travailler pour y sont beaucoup plus
motivés ça leur parle c'est vraiment du
concret et pourtant c'est très riche et
ils apprennent et ça freine énormément
numéros préparés par les maternelles et
mike beijing
encadrés par des artistes professionnels
les enfants apprécient cette immersion
dans le bouddhisme qui fait de la corde
à sauter du trapèze
dijoux de jonglerie du rouleau américain
de l'equilibre sur la boule
ça change de l'école est là il vend
j'aime bien costaud
s'amuse en travaillant l'aboutissement
de ce travail une représentation devant
un public
le cirque pédagogique se déplace dans
plusieurs villages du loiret et
accompagne des centaines d'élèves